Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
for
Fore.
[Silence]
Continuing in the 210th chapter, the
chapter regarding the virtues of the day
of Jum.
In the past weeks, we have listened to
narrations
which discuss
the obligatory nature of bathing for the
occasion of the day of Jum
and bathing specifically for the salah
of Jum.
These narrations that came before speak
about the bare minimum that is required
for a person who attends Jym.
However, not everyone who attends Jumra
receives the ultimate reward of Jym.
What is the ultimate reward of Jumra?
The ultimate reward of Jym is what is
between one Jum and the next of sins is
expated.
And in another narration, what is
between
every two J and an in and an addition of
three days. So 10 days sins
expedated.
This is the ultimate reward of Juma. But
not everyone that attends Juma receives
this reward. Why is that? Because this
reward
has
conditions to it. These conditions have
to be met in order for a person to
receive this reward.
Now many of the people that attend Jum
their Ju
may be valid.
Their J may be valid
meaning that they are not required to
repeat their J their salah is not
invalid. But there is a far cry and a
big difference between
a Ju that is that is
valid and a jum that is rewarding.
Just because a person's jum is valid
doesn't mean that a person's jum is
necessarily rewarding
because there are conditions that if a
person breaks these conditions or fails
to fulfill them this will invalidate the
reward of J not necessarily the salah of
J. So while their salah is technically
still acceptable,
it does not mean that their reward is
still valid. Their reward can be
invalid. The following narrations are
going to be discussing the conditions
for receiving this reward.
Here we have a narration on the
authority of Salman
known as Salman Pharisee.
Salman the Persian because he is from
Persia. He's a very long and illustrious
story. Many of us have probably heard.
However, Salman Pharisee, what is little
known about him is that he lived
over a 100red years.
Many scholars place him at
above the
120 year mark. So he lived to be very
very old many many years. He lived
before Islam and before the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam was a prophet and
messenger. And
the remainder of his life he lived as
a follower of the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and
a follower of the he lived through the
of all of the
and far beyond that
narrates he says the messenger of Allah
said
that no man will bathe on the day of J
and then
and clean himself
as thoroughly as possible.
And then put on
some kind of perfume or some kind of
musk or even if it is only the
incense that is used in his home to
better
set the scent of the home
and then go to attend.
And in doing so, not part between two
people. Not part between two people.
Meaning when there's two people sitting
next to each other, the person comes and
walks between them. Or the person comes
and sits in between two people who are
already sitting next to each other. This
is annoying. This is irritating.
It is an annoyance. And so we understand
here that it's not just this act but any
act that will act any act that will play
a part in annoying the other people that
are attending
and then upon arriving at the masid not
dividing or separating between two
people and pray what Allah has decreed
for him to pray. There is no sunnah
before Jym. There is no set sunnah
before Jum. Person prays of J whatever
they are able to pray. The bare minimum
is two as
the salutation of the masid.
The bare minimum is two upon arriving at
the masid. However, if they wanted to
continue to pray in units of two all the
way until the imam comes and and
you know ascends the mimba then that is
fine as well. However, there's no set
number before jum after jum there is a
set number and Muslim the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
if he would pray the sunnah of J after
in the masid he would pray
four raqa so two sets of two and if he
were to pray in his home or outside of
the masjid then he would pray only two
raqa
and then the person is silent whenever
the imam is speaking. Silence
is not just a verbal silence but ceases
communication with anyone else. Ceases
communication with anyone else. They're
not making noise and they're not
speaking with anyone else even if only
in s with signs. If they are to sign to
someone else while the imam is speaking,
this is still considered to be breaking
a person's silence while the imam is
giving the he says if a person does all
of these things
they will receive the reward of an
experation of sin between that and the
ja to follow. This narration has been
collected by imariham.
Alhamdulillah.